Our lip volume will be because
Increased age or minor bruise
Narrowing with a variety of genetic factors
So by injecting fillers into the lips in the US, the process
Become quite common
Thank you, kylie, what is the trend of this rising trend?
Question?
What happens when you inject lip fillings?
Lip filler is often made up of
Made of hyaluronic acid, hyaluronic acid may be
The safest choice today
Hyaluronic acid in our natural presence in our skin
It is responsible for managing nutrients, hormones
And the movement of cells. Is unlikely to say
After the injection of hyaluronic acid
There will be an allergic reaction. But how does hyaluronic acid work?
Although this process will be because
Human face structure
Related to their own goals
The common process is to deal with deflated
Vermilion or sagging of the upper lip
Once injected with hyaluronic acid
(Hyaluronic acid is a polar sugar), physically
Filled up with lips but also absorbed
Naturally stored moisture in the body
To create more plump lips
Doctors are very likely to use injection hyaluronic acid
To repair your original asymmetrical lips
Or make the shape of the lips like the bow of Cupid
That is, the middle of the upper lip is a little concave.
This shape is considered very young and attractive
Are you afraid of a syringe?
Usually anesthesia is like
You go to the dentist, the doctor uses the same kind of
Or mixing the lip filler itself
To reduce pain. After injection
Within 4~6 months
Lip filler is metabolized by the body
Will follow the individual
Physiological conditions and metabolism vary. But there is any
Side effects? Even with the best
Technology, there will still be a lot in 2 days to 2 weeks
Swollen and indigo
Appeared near the injection site
Short-term complications like a lump can
Being massaged or
Treated with hyaluroidase (this is an enzyme)
It will safely break down the lip filling
And it is done quickly. This enzyme can also be injected
To the lips, if the guests are not satisfied
The result of the operation. In other words, this enzyme can make the surgery not happen.
Long-term or late onset
Impact, like infection, chronic
Inflammation and allergic reactions
It will happen too. But these symptoms
Very rare
They usually follow
Unlicensed person
Surgery related and may only be
Oral medication. The only downside may be
Will spend you 500~2000 dollars
The price is related to the amount you need to inject
So if you are willing to spend your
Money on your lips
Lip surgery may be a safe procedure
And its risk can be minimized
When you give surgery to a licensed doctor
If you are curious about the rest of your body,
Check out our new
Playlist ESOP body. You will learn
About Botox and
Everything about steroids. Thanks for watching and
Subscribe to our watch every Thursday for new videos!